— Salut Romain, ça va ?
— Bof !
Je reviens de chez le médecin.
— Ah mer**, t'es encore malade ?
— Non non non non, je pars en vacances.
Je voulais me faire vacciner contre le sida.
Et euh... il a pas voulu.
— Attends, t'es sérieux là ?
J'sais pas si vous avez remarqué...
Ouais j'ai toujours rêvé de commencer une vidéo comme ça.
J'sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais on entend
beaucoup moins parler du sida ces derniers temps.
♫ J'entends parler du sidaaa ! ♫
Ah, on entend plus trop parler de Raggasonic non plus d'ailleurs.
Ça peut paraître être une bonne nouvelle parce que ça veut dire
que la recherche a fait des progrès, que les choses s'améliorent.
Mais du coup le problème c'est que les gens sont un peu moins bien renseignés.
Alors je vous propose de refaire un petit tour de la question
avec 5 bullshits qu'on entend souvent sur la maladie.
Whoo ok, on commence fort !
Donc on va se mettre d'accord tout de suite !
Non, on n'attrape pas le sida en embrassant quelqu'un.
Et ça pour deux bonnes raisons :
D'abord parce qu'on ne peut pas être contaminé
par un simple échange de salive.
Même si on a des petites plaies dans la bouche.
Ensuite, parce qu'on n'attrape pas vraiment le sida.
Bon je m'explique.
Ce qu'on attrape, c'est un virus !
Le Virus de l'Immunodéficience Humaine - le VIH.
Il est transmis par le sang,
les sécrétions sexuelles ou de la mère à l'enfant
pendant la grossesse ou pendant l'allaitement.
Une fois qu'on a été contaminé par le VIH, on est porteur du virus.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut le transmettre.
On dit qu'on est séropositif parce que la sérologie,
c'est-à-dire la prise de sang qui recherche le virus est positive.
Mais on a pas le sida.
Le sida, c'est le Syndrome de l'ImmunoDéficience Acquise.
Et c'est un ensemble de problèmes qui apparaissent
une fois que le virus s'est attaqué au système immunitaire.
Mais ça apparaît plusieurs années après.
Donc on n'attrape pas vraiment le sida.
On est infecté par le VIH
qui détruit certaines cellules de nos défenses immunitaires.
Et au bout de quelques années, des maladies en profitent pour apparaître.
C'est ça qu'on appelle le SIDA !
Et faut vraiment que j'arrête de faire...
ce geste...
Hein... vraiment...
Alors non, soyons très clairs, on ne guérit pas du sida !
Pas encore.
Et tant qu'on y est, y'a pas de vaccin contre le sida non plus.
Ça existe pas encore.
— Haaaaaa...
— Attention, y'a des traitements !
Ils ont pour but de diminuer la quantité de virus dans le sang,
et de maintenir les cellules de notre système immunitaire en nombre suffisant.
Et donc d'empêcher d'entrer dans la phase finale.
Ces traitements sont tellement efficaces que parfois le virus devient
indétectable dans le sang et qu'on peut avoir la même espérance de vie
que tout le monde quand on est séropositif.
Mais on est pas guéri pour autant !
D'abord parce qu'on est sous traitement à vie pour ça.
Et ensuite parce que la présence du VIH dans l'organisme
provoque une inflammation chronique qui peut finir par déclencher d'autres maladies.
Donc si !
Il faut continuer à se protéger !
Bon ok...
C'est vrai, la confiance c'est important dans un couple.
Mais un : est-ce que vous faîtes aussi confiance à ses ex-partenaires ?
Et deux : y'a pas que le sexe comme mode de contamination.
Donc votre compagne ou votre compagnon a très bien pu être infecté
sans même avoir conscience des risques.
Donc avant de se passer de préservatifs dans un couple,
on check que tout est clean.
Chacun fait son test de dépistage.
Et on attend les résultats avant de faire la grève du latex.
Dans ce cas de figure mais aussi pour tous les cas dans lesquels
vous avez envie de faire une petite vérification.
Il y a partout en France, des CeGIDD.
Il suffit de vous y rendre pour un dépistage par simple prise de sang
pour le VIH mais aussi pour les hépatites
et les infections sexuellement transmissibles.
Hein... Tant qu'on y est...
Voilà, comme ça même si le risque zéro n'existe pas,
vous partez sur des bonnes bases.
Bon n'hésitez pas à refaire un petit dépistage de temps en temps.
Je vous mets les liens des centres dans la description.
C'est faux !
D'abord parce que avant l'éjaculation,
il y a un écoulement de liquide pré-séminal
dans lequel on peut retrouver le virus.
Donc il peut vous infecter, même si votre partenaire se retire
avant le bouquet final.
Ensuite, parce que les organes génitaux sont recouverts de muqueuses.
C'est-à-dire une peau très fine avec des petits vaisseaux sanguins très proches de la surface.
Et qu'avec le frottement, y'a un risque de contamination.
Donc pour être très clair !
En cas de pénétration anale ou vaginale...
Préservatif !
En cas d'échange de sextoys...
Ça, c'est la base !
Bon maintenant pour les rapports oraux-génitaux...
Oraux-génitaux c'est pas une marque de gâteau,
ça veut dire fellation ou cunnilingus.
Notez que le risque est négligeable pour celui ou celle
sur qui on pratique l'acte.
Mais qu'il peut y en avoir un pour celui ou celle qui est au boulot.
Donc... pour la fellation, le risque existe,
notamment si le sirop d'amour est déversé dans la bouche.
Le seul moyen de prendre zéro risque, c'est le préservatif.
Le mieux c'est de les choisir sans lubrifiant voire aromatisés.
En plus ça protège aussi des infections sexuellement transmissibles.
Pour le cunnilingus, le risque est faible.
Mais il ne peut pas être complètement écarté
surtout si les muqueuses génitales ou celles de la bouche sont abîmées.
Et puis, il y a toujours les IST.
Si vous voulez réduire le risque à zéro,
vous pouvez utiliser des digues.
Un peu comme chez le dentiste, mais sans la roulette.
C'est un rectangle de latex que vous tenez entre votre bouche et la zone.
Hein... Un préservatif pour la langue quoi...
Mais... plat.
L'anulingus maintenant.
C'est une pratique à faible risque pour le VIH.
Mais pour l'hépatite A...
Donc même consigne, si vous voulez éviter tout risque...
La digue.
♫ De Nantes à Montaigu la digue la digue ! ♫
Pour le reste et notamment pour les risques liés aux injections.
Ne partagez pas vos seringues.
Ne partagez pas non plus vos pailles.
Hein.. Si vous vous mettez des pailles dans le nez.
Notamment à cause des risques liés aux muqueuses irritées.
De manière générale, ne partagez pas d'objets en contact
avec du sang ou des sécrétions sexuelles.
Alors évidemment, c'est mieux si ça n'arrive pas.
Mais en cas de craquage, il y a les TPE.
Non... Pas ceux que vous donnent les profs au lycée.
Là on parle de...
Donc si la capote a craqué ou que vous craignez d'avoir été exposé
au VIH de quelque manière que ce soit.
Vous pouvez aller aux urgences et demander à être vu
être vu rapidement par le médecin référent.
Vous pouvez aussi aller dans un service spécialisé dans ce genre de suivi.
En cas de doute ou pour connaître l'adresse du centre le plus proche.
N'hésitez pas à appeler Sida Info Service
au 0 800 840 800.
On vous répondra 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24.
Sur place, la personne qui vous recevra, évaluera les risques
et mettra en place un traitement si besoin.
Plus le traitement est pris tôt, plus il est efficace.
Alors il diminue le risque d'être contaminé,
mais attention il le supprime pas complètement.
Donc il vous faudra peut-être ensuite un suivi et un dépistage pour être sûr.
Mais ça c'est le médecin qui vous le dira.
Voilà donc surtout n'oubliez pas.
On entend moins parler du sida mais il est toujours là.
Et il y a 18 millions de personnes séropositives dans le Monde
qui n'ont toujours pas accès au traitement.
Donc la recherche, les projets d'aide aux malades et les associations
ont toujours besoin de soutien.
Si vous voulez apporter votre pierre à l'édifice,
vous pouvez donnez 5 euros au Sidaction juste en envoyant
"Don" par SMS au 92110.
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui.
On se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos.
En attendant, prenez soin de vous, prenez soin des autres.
Mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous bien.